24 7. hey what's up I'm Kim BHD here and
yesterday was Apple's WWDC their
worldwide developer conference event
their big software event every year
where they go over a bunch of new
features for all their os's we got new
iOS 15 stuff we got new iPad OS 15 stuff
and we got Mac OS Monterey a bunch of
other stuff now I do plan on making a
separate video going over some stuff in
more detail especially I want to talk
about iPad OS 15 because I think they
made some interesting changes some of
which did what I wanted but also some of
it didn't so make sure you subscribe to
see that when it does come out but I
couldn't help but notice yesterday
watching all these new features get
unveiled for the iPhone for iOS 15. that
a lot of them were familiar because
we've seen them before
and Android now this isn't new at all
like this this literally happens
basically every single developer event
like every WWDC we see features in the
iPhone that we've already seen in
Android and every Google I O we also see
some stuff that we've seen in previous
iPhones it's fine I actually literally
just made a video my last one about why
companies should copy the good stuff
from each other
but there is a trend that mainly Apple's
features come later
and also arguably typically better like
you probably all remember how widgets
literally widgets and an app drawer and
picture-in-picture were all famously
late to iOS 14 last year after being an
Android for a while well there was a
bunch of new iOS 15 features now that
were just announced many of which are
really cool
also many of which have been in Android
for a while
just slightly different so I think ios's
new live text feature is like the
perfect example of this okay so live
text takes any image in your gallery or
in the camera recognizes any text inside
of it and then just lets you long press
to copy and paste that real life text
anywhere else you want it feels kind of
like magic if you can just lift
handwritten text or printed text and
labels Etc and take them put them
anywhere else in any other app if you
took a picture of a business with a sign
out front you can long press the text on
that sign and look them up or call their
phone number and it'll even do some more
complex image recognition where if you
take a picture of a pet or something
It'll recognize that it's a dog you can
long press the dog and it'll tell you
what breed of dog it is so that's pretty
cool now I don't know if you've ever
used Google lens on an Android phone but
it's basically the exact same thing as
all the stuff we've just described and
it's been around for a while you can
point Google Lens at literally anything
with text in it give it a second and
it'll let you copy and paste that real
life text again into whatever you want
on your phone translate it in Google
search
Etc that's built into the viewfinder of
a lot of phones and inside phones like
the pixel that use Google photos as the
default photos app you can hit the lens
button at any point to find and copy and
paste any text or look up similar images
with object recognition and it isn't
always perfect but it is impressively
accurate sometimes it does way more than
just pets too now on most Android phones
it isn't quite as as seamless feeling as
apples where if I'm just looking at a
photo in the gallery and I see a phone
number on a sign just long pressing that
phone number and being able to call
right away is a slight step faster than
having to go through hitting the Google
Lens button and copying and pasting but
I feel like you can almost guarantee
that will now be lifted into Google's
next version FaceTime got a bunch of
neat little features like spatial audio
and blurred background portrait mode and
different microphone modes so you can
choose standard or isolating voices or
wide spectrum mode depending on
background noise but probably the
biggest addition is called share play
which lets you watch things and share
things like your screen inside of
FaceTime now
you've been able to screen share inside
of Google meet Zoom teams whatever else
you use for forever but FaceTime now
being able to do this it's a little more
well integrated than the others because
here you're now listening to Apple music
with this nice UI and it's all synced up
or you can watch TV shows or movies with
synced playback controls so if somebody
pauses it pauses for everyone if
somebody fast forwards to show you
something it fast forwards for both of
you so everyone can see the same thing
at the same time it's super easy to stay
in sync and of course developer
conference gold shareplay will have a
new API so any developer that makes a
media app will be able to plug into this
and make it work in FaceTime so I think
you already have HBO ESPN Disney and I
imagine things like Netflix Spotify in
the future YouTube hopefully but the
point is all this stuff is better than
the typical like screen sharing while
you play a video where you're getting
like 5 to 10 FPS and it depends on your
internet connection it's just not quite
as good as it being built in the way it
is here oh also by the way small detail
you can now share FaceTime links to
anyone
just anyone who can click a link which
means you can join a FaceTime call from
the web on an Android phone or a Windows
desktop
I guess now we can officially say we
have FaceTime on Android never thought
I'd say that but you can say it now
Apple also added on device voice
recognition so it works offline and much
faster which feels like a huge step up
for Siri which you guessed it is
catching up to a Google assistant and
Google voice recognition has been doing
on pixels since 2019 that I've been
absolutely loving they also improve
their photo memories feature which
strongly resembles Google photos memory
feature and they added a lot of really
cool street level features to Apple maps
that continue to make big strides
actually towards catching up to and
matching Google Maps there's way more
street view level information and
there's an AR View and a few select
cities get these really detailed maps
where 3D models of landmarks are dropped
in there so yeah clearly you can see the
trend a lot of these new features new
features that'll show up on the iPhone
have already been in Google's versions
for a while ever it seems like every
time the iPhone gets new features
they've been somewhere in some Android
phone before so why the question is why
it's not like Apple's just choosing to
be later all the time there's good
reasons for it and it turns out of
course Google is incredible software
company and that's why they've been so
Innovative there for a long time but
also Apple's teams have a distinct focus
on this ecosystem thing that we've
talked about so I've made an entire
video about the ecosystem I'll link it
below the like button if you want to
watch it but it's a huge Focus for Apple
not just to make good new stuff but to
make everything plug into each other
seamlessly because of course it makes
the products better but it also makes it
harder to leave the ecosystem they think
about this constantly people might like
their iPhones but really love their
airpods so it's harder to leave the
iPhone because of how well they work
with the airpods and how much they love
them or maybe it's air tags or iMessage
or airdrop with the Mac there's tons of
these but it's not just devices it's
also the increasing number of services
they make too it's Apple new use it's
Apple TV it's iMessage it's FaceTime so
while Google's teams can be ridiculously
Innovative because the teams are a
little more siled and they get to work
sort of without the constraints of
having to talk to each other all the
time they will often churn out amazing
incredible new features that just don't
talk to anything else meanwhile Apple's
teams even if they have the exact same
idea at the exact same time as Google's
teams they will often have this
constraint of having to work with the
rest of the ecosystem and plug into as
many different things as possible which
often multiplies the amount of time
needed to make the thing work but the
end result is typically something that's
got some functionality or some plugs
that the other versions don't so with
notifications for example we've I mean
Android notifications have just been
better than ios's since the beginning of
time just facts but iOS 15 did get some
new notification stuff and one of the
newest feature teachers I really liked
is called Focus modes and this is sick
so as someone who likes customization it
kind of feels like multiple profiles on
your iPhone or at least as close as
they've ever gotten to it so you can set
your phone to do not disturb mode or
sleeping mode or personal or work mode
and when your focus mode is set to work
for example you only get notifications
from your work apps and your work
contacts and when it's set to personal
it Grays out all of your work apps and
work contacts and has a separate set of
things you can do and you can even set a
new home screen for your non-work focus
mode now there have been some Android
phones with like a work profile mode and
that's not super new but the cherry on
top now is when you set that Focus mode
on your iPhone all of the other iCloud
devices also now will switch to that
same work Focus mode and have that same
restriction so you set it on your iPhone
at some time can be triggered by a time
of day or location or whatever then your
iPad your Mac your watch everything is
now also locked to that same same set of
restrictions and your iMessage status
will also now show as in work Focus mode
to everyone that usually connects with
you over iMessage so that's a lot of
extra work to make all of that work but
now hey everything's working together as
you'd expect it to you saw how they tied
iMessage into Apple news where if
someone sends you an article and
messages it'll appear in the for you
section of the Apple news app like I
don't see Google adding seamless
integration between Google messages and
Google news I mean maybe it will
eventually but those apps and those
teams that make them don't really seem
to work together at all that continuity
feature you saw of dragging your cursor
from your Mac to your iPad back and
forth seamlessly and literally dragging
and dropping files between them that is
one of the coolest slickest ecosystem
Flex features I think I've ever seen and
I don't know how many years we would
have to wait to see Google doing that
with a Chrome OS laptop and an Android
tablet but I would hold my breath that's
just one of the things that Apple does
so well that they take extra time for
but that ends up being really great uh
Dieter from The Verge did a really great
video recently you should watch on how
Apple's sort of been laying the
groundwork for stuff like that over the
years but the bottom line is it's what
we've come to expect
so
yeah we wait for it so that's just a fun
theme I figured I would highlight also
if you've been hanging out in the
official MKBHD Discord you already know
this but we've been chatting over all
the new stuff that Apple's announced at
WWDC if you haven't already joined over
there I'll leave a link below and also
I'm gonna host a Discord stage Channel
event in our Discord uh today this
afternoon
I'll put a Time below and I'll have some
YouTube friends in there and we'll talk
about some of these WWDC announcements
but also the themes of like which
features we saw in Android and places
we've seen before versus what's new in
iOS 15 and on the iPad it'll be fun we
should hang out we should chat over
there but also for those of you in the
YouTube comments section let me know
this
do you have a preference between super
Innovative new bleeding edge features
versus a little bit later but a little
bit more well polished or plugged in
features let me know what you think of
that
okay either way that's been it thanks
for watching catch you guys in the next
one peace